das ist in ihrer reportage über sexuelle
übergriffe
anders als einige kommentar und felix
erfreut und nahm sehr viel dazu größere
dass sie sehr stark und mutig und das
durch die betroffenen zu öffentlich zu
begrüßen zum beispiel der für morgen
findet stark von den männern die sich
getraut haben über das sprechen oder
sony an respekt an diese männer dass sie
dies öffentlich thematisieren
einschnitte er schon lange nötig ist und
sicher vielen anderen betroffenen
männern mut macht schoko sahne sekunden
das durchweg so viel die männer
bestärkten und fehlen auf eine eigene
übergriff geschrieben sondern auch sehr
mutig gefunden dass sie das taten die
der kommentar jetzt werde ich nur wieder
die fragen und kommentaren der lukas zum
beispiel der heckscheibe super
spannendes thema und doch hätte es aber
auch spannend gefunden von menschen zu
hören die von frauen missbraucht wurden
ich denke diese bereiche ist noch
tabuisiert das handlungsballett
kritisierte bibel steht er in der
gkv gedanken darüber gemacht im vorfeld
von minuten reportage und ich jetzt im
inneren wäsche schauen ich mit zehn
anderen gerät wo sexuelle übergriffe
fahrer hemd und einer von einem anderen
ist von meiner frau belästigt wurde und
das deckt sich auch mit der expertin
nicht
einmal bestätigt dass man schon davon
ausgeht dass mehr frauen sind
sexualisierte gewalt erlebt was man dort
dazu aber muss sagen ist natürlich das
dunkel sie versehen martin bachmann hat
mir gesagt dass erst viel halt dass man
wenn sie von frauen missbraucht wartet
nur viel scham behaftet oder das thema
daher gönnt aus wenn es für andere
länder sind und doch immer mal wieder
zudem bilde gesellschaft oder der mann
ist er der täter und nicht da wo schwach
ist und frau erwartet nicht dass täter
die xii ich werde aber auf jeden fall
beim thema logo und nur vitra
recherchieren denn hat mitarbeiter oder
dmb geschrieben es bestehe überhaupt
nicht dass solche straftaten überhaupt
verjähren ich habe das sehr schlimm dass
die tat im nachhinein schon volljährig
und haben mich darum nochmal die
juristin vom slf erkundigt und er klagt
wieso ist die verjährungsfrist im
strafrecht gibt und zwar ist das so dass
mit hofer gott ab gerade bei solchen
sachen immer schwieriger wird und nur
seit halt auch dass die härteste strafe
das unrecht quasi ungeschehen machen
außer dem wetter gesetzgeber mit der
karriere zum ausdruck bringen dass
gesellschaftliche bedürfnis nach mehr
staatlicher ausglich und noch eine
strafe mit der zeit noch als im
strafrecht und gerade im
sexualstrafrecht sind die
verjährungsfrist umstritten weil es ist
schon ein unterschied ob es gestohlen
wird oder aber promis blut dreht und das
zeigt eine volksinitiative wo auch noch
oder nicht und die hat gesagt dass es
ein unverjährbarkeit gebiete strafe
folglich unter strafe sexueller und
pornografischer straftaten an kindern
vor der pubertät
wird jährige außerdem entscheidend was
höchststrafe ist vor der tat und im fall
von der vergewaltigung und der sexuellen
nötigung weg gemeinde 15 denn er wisse
ob es denn so ist das wenn frauen
vergewaltigt wird dass das sexuelle
nötigung vergewaltigung gilt genau das
ist es so alle erzwungene penetration
von der mensch außer die vaginale
situation mit einem penis galt als
sexuelle nötigung und vergewaltigung
einer frau aus einer quelle von der user
von mir ich sei ja klar es erfahren
deutlich mehr frauen sexualisierte
übergriffe als männer die zahlen oder
die user zahlen zum bundesamt für
statistik danach verglichen zum beispiel
wie viel männer und wie für frauen die
sich eine 2600 genötigt wurde sind und
wie für frauen vergewaltigt wurde sind
mit dem anger sind das 30 21
706 benötigt wurde sind und 608 frauen
und vergewaltigt wurde sind 737 frage
was man dazu aber natürlich auch sagen
muss ist weder dunkelziffer wer davon
ausgeht dass man als ich wenige mal wenn
ein service basiert sind als frauen denn
hätte philipp geschrieben habe sehr
großen respekt gegenüber den
porträtierten besser gute die
verständlich vergewaltigung anno dazumal
so definiert das würde mich mal
interessieren aber bedarf mit dem martin
bachmann cracker und er hat gesagt dass
aigner und wahrscheinlich dazu geführt
hat dass das so definiert wurde ist das
mit seiner frau nach einer
vergewaltigung schwanger werden
denn der markt seinen erfolgen dass
walnüsse ich würde noch interessieren ob
es irgendwelche tipps zur verarbeitung
oder erkennung eines sexuellen
übergriffs gibt dornig jetzt im logo zum
beispiel nachgefragt und erhält mit
folgendes geschrieben
für magische sie dass er 94 kult können
darüber zu reden mich einfach keine
lücke was passiert ist zum dank für das
sichere hilft egal ob mit der familie
mit dem partner oder der partnerin mit
freundinnen oder psychologin wie immer
und mir persönlich als auch cool für das
ganze zeugs bringen und dass es soeben
offiziell wird nur dazu hätte
geschrieben ich auch selber mega mega
lang so extrem unterdrückt dass es
niemals mit geholt aber dank reden hilft
also dass man mit dem umfeld allgemein
über das thema redet dass man das umfeld
schafft wo alle wissen dass sie so
sachen pc für ihn ist aber das falsche
bild das hat es doch nicht erzählen kann
und niemand glaubt schlimmsten der
manuela geschrieben dass es ein langer
prozess sondern auch jetzt noch und das
heißt wie sie aber gebracht hat wenn die
depressionen oder die schlechte phasen
aufkommen dass er immer latent bedankt
und dass sie sich mit neuen vertrauten
auseinandersetzt das ist schwierig mit
der anderen sich auseinandersetzen aber
hätte weiter töten vom reiter irgendwie
überwunden dass er sich gerne öfter dass
er mit anderen keine rede und dann merkt
dass es ihm dann besser gott er schrieb
mir seit sowohl sich selber die besten
helfer sie aber auf hilfe anderer rolle
wenn der winter die frage hängt dann
steht jetzt keine kommentare
und was - einige war wenn er einen
themenvorschlag könnten auch sehr gerne
kommentar stand und wenn er keine
rotation renz quasi vorweg dann aber
doch der kanal